ich habe mich heute aufgeregt über
andrea nahles man glaubt es kaum andrea
nahles das ist die frau wir ändern uns
die pippi langstrumpf gesungen hat im
bundestag das wm-team die man auf
englisch sagt den hauptsorge ändern und
ich mach mir die welt widdewidde wie sie
mir gefällt zustand sie davon pläne und
st zur verwunderung der abgeordneten die
sich dabei aber
es gibt eine nachricht dazu ein gerücht
was ungefähr seit zehn tagen durch
berlin geistert andrea nahles soll
demnach dem nicht neue
gesundheitsministerin im kabinett der
abt regierung werden dass die ziemlich
unter deck decke gestern abend des
markus lanz in seiner sendung als
gerücht öffentlich gemacht man fragt
sich wirklich andrea nahles
gesundheitsministerin wir erinnern uns
für zweieinhalb jahren ist andrea nahles
knall auf fall an einem sonntag
zurückgetreten von allen ämtern
parteivorsitz fraktionsvorsitz und auch
ihr abgeordnetenmandat und
weggeschmissen bei die spd ist ein
bisschen unter druck war sie auch als
bei der europawahl nur 15 8 prozent
erzielt ein schlechtes ergebnis aber sie
wollte das alles nicht mehr ist
abgehauen ab ins in die eifel ins
rheinland ihrer heimat und ward nicht
mehr gesehen
fast wie bei so einem burnout und jetzt
als gesundheitsministerin im gespräch
als amt also das amt dass neben dem
kanzler sicherlich das herausforderndste
ist von allen weil man muss die großen
großen brocken weg vor allem die da sind
bunt sie muss dann die impfpflicht
durchsetzen im frühjahr nächsten jahres
und zu welchen emotionen das wird haben
wir heute abend hier gesehen das braucht
jemand der wirklich stabil ist wer bei
sich ist er sich durchsetzen kann und
auch die mentale stärke hat sowas gegen
größte anfeindungen durchzusetzen und
durch zu stellen andrea nahles wäre für
mich die völlig falsche besetzung
benehmen karl lauterbach hat immer
genannt der ist ein großer experte
könnte das amt ministeriell aber nicht
führen warum holt man nicht ulla schmidt
zurück die amtierende die längst
amtierende gesundheitsministerin die es
je gegeben hat fachlich hoch kompetent
mit 72 immer noch fitter als für die mit
52 und außerdem eine frau die starke
nerven hat genau das braucht man genau
solche frauen braucht das land
vela guter punkt also und ich finde es
toll dass du uns hier immer noch mal
wieder ein bisschen amüsement einstreu
ist also ulla schmidt ist jetzt ganz das
gemischte das können wir noch ist ein
sträucher regional ist das gerücht hat
schon hand und fuß oder ulla schmidt
meine ich jetzt der name ist jetzt wer
denn du genannt hast das finde ich
bemerkenswert wir wissen auch was ja
unter ulla schmidt im gesundheitssystem
passiert ist und deswegen wer meine mein
vorschlag eigentlich der spd dieses
ministerium komplett zu nehmen wir haben
ein gesundheitssystem was völlig durch
so sozialisiert ist
der sozialismus regiert und ich glaube
es wäre viel besser wenn beispielsweise
die fdp dieses ministerium hätte wenn
wir über das thema kosten nach denn es
gibt eine totale intransparenz die man
weiß was kostet eigentlich ein notarzt
ruft ja wenn er kommt und ich rufe ihn
einfach machen damit zeitig als
kassenpatient 10 euro die ganze fahrt
kurz aber 1000 euro weiß gerne jemand
was kostet ein arztbesuch also diese
intransparenz die wir haben mit vielen
fehlanreizen ich glaube deswegen weg von
der spd andrea nahles in allen ehren auf
keinen fall rasch nach hause nur zu
sagen die iwf gesagt die mehr wertigkeit
gehabt die geliebte fdp hätte die
möglichkeit gehabt seine hände weg davon
lieber nehmen wir das
verkehrsministerium oder alle anderen
ministerien dieser welt bloß nicht das
gesundheitsministerium deswegen hohen
respekt dafür vor dem oder derjenigen
der bereit ist die bereit ist dieses
amtes also ich finde ja eine andere
frage ist entscheidend ich glaube dass
derjenige der das wird oder egal welches
amt in der regierung anstrebt dass er
ein bisschen ahnung davon haben sollte
also in einer verteidigungsminister wird
glaube ich schadet es nicht wenn er
selber einmal gedient hat mal um ein
beispiel zu nehmen also ich würde jetzt
nicht als fokussiert justizminister
werden ich könnte das auch nicht muss
ich ganz offen sagen und deswegen ist es
mir eigentlich egal wer das macht soll
ich finde die leute haben anspruch
darauf dass leute minister werden die
ein bisschen ahnung von dem haben was
sie dann machen das ist ja interessant
dass ich sagen wenn man daran denkt wie
ihre partei in den letzten jahren immer
wieder das verteidigungsministerium
besitzt hat aber das nur als kleiner als
kleine neben mir mehr geld für frauen
noch nicht damals ja
ich finde es extrem
bemerkenswert was im
gesundheitsministerium in den letzten
zwei jahren passiert ist man kann und
man muss auch jens spahn hat dafür
kritisieren was passiert ist aber wenn
man sich überlegt was war das
gesundheitsministerium vor der pandemie
im
ministerium in dem in aller regel
gesetze gemacht wurden und gesetze macht
man so weit ich den prozess kenne doch
auch er ausgeruht da brennt nichts an
natürlich braucht man wahnsinnig viel
fachkompetenz muss das irgendwann
hinbekommen und dann natürlich auch
durch bekommen aber jetzt ist das ist
dieses ministerium in dem so viele leute
ist jetzt die eigentlich gesetzte
geschrieben haben und sich mit
gesetzestexten und konzepten befasst hat
ist ein krisen management ministerium
geworden für das gesamte land und
deswegen glaube ich der nächste
gesundheitsminister muss da uns die
pandemie aladag erhalten bleiben wird
vor allem erst mal ein ganz anderer typ
sein es muss ein macher sein und da ist
sind wir vielleicht gar nicht ganz einer
meinung und nicht unbedingt einer der
arzt war oder der sich mit gesundheit
primär auskennt es wäre toll ist er
absolut wünschenswert fachkenntnis ist
immer essentiell aber ich glaube es muss
ein krisenmanager sein der durch diese
krise kommt noch ein letzter nachtrag
auch wenn man denkt wie israel agiert
hat im vergleich zu uns wie schnell die
die impfstoffe hatten wie die exekutiert
das ist einfach im deutschen
gesundheitsministerium glaube ich in der
dna überhaupt nicht vorhanden ja und
jetzt haben wir ein krisen management
manager in general zwei sterne general
aber auch da wäre es falsch natürlich
alles auf den zu richten und zu sagen
der soll alles nun leisten was im
gesundheitsministerium möglicherweise
nicht gemacht wird denn da muss es ja
tatsächlich auch entschieden werden und
gemacht werden macher oder macherin im
gesundheitsministerium ist der pflicht
obwohl es natürlich schwierig ist wenn
die faxgeräte noch in gesundheitsämtern
stehen stellt als
bundesgesundheitsminister also
eigentlich brauchen wir ein ablaufdatum
für faxgeräte in deutschland das wäre
mal was sie da ist übrigens gab es
zumindest was das thema vernetzung der
gesundheitsämter angeht da gab es ja
immer wieder daten die eigentlich dann
zu dieses sogenannte sommer system zudem
alle gesundheitsämter angeschlossen sein
sollten das letzte datum war der 28
februar 2021 und wir haben jüngst wieder
eine umfrage der bild gemacht und habe
festgestellt immer noch sind viele viele
gesundheitsämter an dieses system nicht
angebunden wie kann das sein ich würde
gerne nochmal zu andrea nahles zurück
kommen wir das war ja der ausgangspunkt
des andrea nahles nicht
gesundheitsministerin werden soll und du
hast gesagt bela sie ist weggelaufen ja
ich hatte eher das gefühl auch mit den
leuten mit denen ich gesprochen habe
dass sie raus gemobbt wurde dass sie
trotzdem im gegensatz zu anderen männern
wie sigmar gabriel oder auch gerhard
schröder der als sehr gelobt wird in der
runde nichts schlechtes über die partei
gesagt hat sie und olaf scholz sollen
nahe sein die sollen auch telefonieren
die sollen kontakt haben wenn ich jetzt
bundeskanzlerin werden würde dann würde
ich doch auch minister um mich haben
wollen wenig vertrauen kann und die
gehören im selben flügel ja auch eher an
als olaf scholz und andere politiker
deswegen ich weiß gar nicht warum andrea
nahles so eine schlechte wahl wäre ich
finde sie es damals in voerde gegangen
ohne nachzutreten und was hätte sie
damals zu was hätte sie jetzt tun sollen
ich finde das hat er nichts von weg
laufen ja andrea nahles richtig wird
sich freuen über dein lob und wer weiß
vielleicht sehen wir sie ja wieder nicht
als gesundheitsministerin sondern als
andere den dorsten wichtigen punkt
ausgesprochen da gibt es ein
vertrauensverhältnis sie deckt die linke
ab innerhalb der partei und fabulieren
wir mal über das arbeitsministerium oder
was anderes aber als
gesundheitsministerin der sie sicherlich
fehl am platze weggelaufen ist sie weil
sie ein bisschen kritik hatte an ihrer
person eine ihrer parteiführung und in
solchen situationen wenn das ergebnis
mal nicht so ist wie es ist mein gott
was er der olaf stolz machen sollen oder
alle anderen die mit schlechten
ergebnissen konfrontiert waren steht man
man bleibt da auch das gehört zur
politik dazu uns meist nicht alle ämter
die einem anvertraut worden sind auch wo
ja auch hoffnung hinter stecken auch
personen die ihr heim das vertrauen
ausgesprochen haben nun mal ein bisschen
kriselt das gesundheitssystem ist ja
auch mehr oder das
gesundheitsministerium mehr als jetzt
einfach nur coca cola ist zurzeit das
alles dominante thema aber das wird er
lange plant das wird sondern lange
bleiben aber es gibt ja weitere themen
im
gesundheitsministerium die
beispielsweise sich beschäftigen mit der
finanzierung der gesetzlichen
krankenkassen die sich mit der
pflegeversicherung beschäftigen also mit
vielen vielen dingen die abseits von
corona auch gemanagt werden müssen und
deswegen glaube ich ist es wichtig neben
einem krisenmanager natürlich der auch
lust darauf hat jemanden zu haben der
schon die marktwirtschaft ein bisschen
durchschaut das tut angela andrea nahles
natürlich nichts die kommt von aus der
sozialistischen ecke und die frage muss
glaube ich schon sein wie wir ein system
in einer älter werdenden gesellschaft
und dann noch mit dem fall corona
überhaupt einigermaßen finanzierbar
halten wir wissen dass die zuschüsse aus
dem bundeshaushalt nicht nur an die
rentenkasse sondern auch in
die krankenversicherung jährlich steigen
gibt immer höhere zuschüsse weil die
krankenkassen nicht mehr auskommen mit
ihrem geld also glaube ich ist es
wichtig einen krisenmanager zu haben
aber zusätzlich auch einzahlen manager
der schon weiß wie wichtig ist es auch
marktwirtschaftliche anreize zu setzen
und es braucht jemanden der nicht nur
diese defizite sieht faxgeräte sind ein
großes beispiel dafür und passendes
beispiel sondern auch die
durchsetzungskraft hat dieses zu ändern
jungs war ganz interessant der jens
spahn am
anfang letztes jahr auch noch war der
beliebteste politiker alle gesagt ein
super gesundheitsminister ich finde das
nicht so gut in deutschland dass man
leute die da am boden liegen noch mal
drauf tritt dann wenn es nicht gut läuft
und ich sonst nicht geschlossen da habe
ich gar nicht verstanden er hatte doch
so ein gute nacht und auf welche weise
das letzte jahr sollte noch
bundeskanzler werden und jetzt auf
einmal oder aber ich lebens nicht nehmen
es gibt 300 menschen gibt kein biontech
mehr haben wir nicht nimmt moderner
wissen dass die leute alle piontek
wollen also er hat schon am ende da
ziemlich daneben gegriffen gut das war
halt auch so dass dieses ministerium hat
es glaube ich ja gerade auch gesagt ein
ministerium war das einfach gesetze
gemacht hat und man hat einfach gestellt
und war froh da sind wir auch beim thema
steuereinnahmen und ausgeglichener
haushalt sind froh gewesen dass man das
alles irgendwie finanzieren konnte am
ende war das ja auch dieses ministerium
der kitt zwischen schwarz und rot ja ich
schieb das geld was übrig ist ins
gesundheitsministerium rein und alle
sind zufrieden und es ist ruhe im karton
es gibt keinen krach in der koalition
super und dann machen wir noch eine
wohltat
ich bin nicht gegen wohltaten ich bin
nur immer der meinung wir müssen sie uns
leisten können und wir sehen in der
jetzigen situation da wird es jetzt
richtig richtig eng und richtig
schwierig schuldenbremse einhalten und
gleichzeitig eine gute
gesundheitspolitik machen das ist sehr
schwer